to oncologists not recognize any benefits of other care. I wouldn't necessarily agree
with that. I think there are a lot of oncologists that do recognize the benefits of other care,
but from a medical legal standpoint, their hands are tied. Unless they have their own private
practice, they have to follow the guidelines of the practice that they belong to or the health
care system that they belong to, or they will be in trouble. So they can't recommend supplements,
they can't recommend hypermectin, they can't recommend rife machines, they can't recommend
fennbenazone, they would get into trouble. So there they are products of the system that they
belong to, and in order to not live with that mental disconnect, they have to basically buy
into what they're doing. Or they, you know, it's just not healthy mentally for them. So that's what
happens. So I do think there's a lot of good oncologists out there that want what's best for their
patients. And if you don't feel like you have one, I'd suggest maybe look for somebody else.